you have a podcast with your with your
uh old co-star and buddy
uh donald faison you guys have this
podcast where you
talk about scrubs yeah well when before
code happened
you know someone approached us and said
the two two gals from the office had
done this and it becomes
really popular and they said you guys
ever want to do this and
they and they said you know you just sit
around and you watch it's not live you
watch the episode beforehand and you sit
around and joke about it
right so john and i said it was great
that'd be fun yeah blast
then coven starts and literally the day
we were set to record they locked down
the city
and we said oh that's too bad that would
have been fun it actually they said
don't worry we'll bring you the the
fancy microphone which i have here
oh that's the old xk11 320.
oh you know it is the uh yeah you
probably actually know what it is
i don't know it brought us the gear and
once a week we do it on zoom
and we thought it would just be like i
honestly thought it would be a handful
of scrubs fans and then like our parents
but it became huge internationally huge
and um so once a week we tell stories we
go on
long ass random tangents we make each
other laugh we tell nostalgic
embarrassing anecdotes and it's become
huge that's great that's fantastic the
um the only thing that's weird is that i
thought it was a joke at first but
donald says that he is
broadcasting from a closet
in his house yes and then i found out
that it's real
he really does broadcast from his closet
yes because donald is encoded with two
small children
who want to know where the hell dad is
right and so his initial plan was i have
to hide from these kids
and our engineer was like actually your
closet's not bad because of all the
acoustics will be great so but now he
like barricades himself
in the closet so that the kids of course
now after doing it this many episodes
they come in there it's funny we just
started having it be
i thought it i mean this reminds me of
you because i think you once told me
when i was in the show like i like to
show the scenes like if there's a mess
mistakes mistakes are gold you want
mistakes you want
people to see that it's real right and i
actually it's funny it's just i didn't
even think of this when i was going to
come on the show but i thought i thought
of you telling me that years ago because
we had stuff where it's like
his wife comes on and she's like honey
the exterminator's here he has to spray
the closet and
and we're like okay so we just we like
we don't we don't edit that stuff out
the exterminator comes in
we start talking to him about being an
exterminator like you know
his daughter uh i mean we just we just
have it all come on the
all in the show because it's just it's
funny now i want to ask you uh
i know a little bit about the podcast
business and merchandising
yes i was surprised the minute you start
working in the podcast world
uh the merch people come to you and say
you need merch you need merchandising
and i didn't think that they were
serious because i thought but apparently
that's that's been a big thing for you
guys it's been a little bit of a journey
the merchandise
you learned this from i'm sure you're
you're your show that
they come to you and they go oh just you
know because i wasn't super into
podcasts i mean like
a handful of them but i i've been on a
bunch but they say oh this is a little
bit of a trivial
trivia not trivia a anecdotal what's the
word it's a thing podcast fans love they
love
merch they like a mug with their
favorite show they like a t-shirt
and we were like okay we've never made
merch for anything but sure
so we put out some [ __ ] t-shirt and
a mug
and the fans on all our social media
started making fun of us like what is
this
horrible merch it was it wasn't good
merch no they did not like their merch
it was basically just our logo with on a
shirt or a mug
so donald and i get very competitive
we're we're very competitive people we
did not like this angle
so we said we're going all in we are
going to spend more time
coming up with with random ass merch for
the people
right so we did that all right so let me
ask you something because i have
something here and i don't know what's
going on
this looks to be um this looks to be a
hand towel is this a hand towel
it's a washcloth okay here's the deal
with this
donald donald hadn't brought this whole
theory onto the um
to the podcast that conan that's yours
by the way to keep
i get to keep this yes thank you
donald has this theory that
african-american people universally
bring a washcloth in the shower
whereas caucasians don't ha
and then it began we have an
african-american female producer and she
weighed in heavily saying yes all of her
african-american friends also bring
washclaws in the shower
interesting from the south started
weighing in said no it's not just about
that it says
it's where you grew up people from the
south bring wash closet
so this joke about wash cloths in the
shower became a running gag
and we said you know what we're making
we're making the people
uh washcloths so this i can take into
the shower with me
i know you can wash your mom you're
supposed to wash your butt with it
wait your butt you're supposed to wash
your butt with it yeah that's the idea i
think i think
you think you have to know you can't
tell me to do that on a whim
i need to first of all that's not what i
would have thought i would not have
thought
i would have thought oh you use it to
put the hot water up against
well you can get a better shade you can
use it for whatever you'd like
i think that the idea for people who are
washcloth users
is that they get in all the cracks and
crevices and nooks and crannies with it
if that's the case then the order in
which you do it is very important
this was part of our debate because they
can't start with the ass
and then conan this was part of our
debate i said you
you folks who do this how often are you
swapping out the washcloth are you doing
a new one every day or does it just live
in the shower for a week
let me check this out this uh is a
christmas ornament
yes sir that's a uh that is me riding
donald
um that's in riding donald yes so on the
show scrubs um there was a whole stick
we used to do where i'd ride on his back
and
we'd yell eagle and um and it was just a
stupid thing i improv one episode
and it became a fan favorite thing so
now we have christmas ornaments with us
eagling on them
well what i'm going to do is i'm going
to put this on my christmas tree this
year better and i want you to send me a
picture i want you to lie i know
i i know your wife and i'm going to text
her and say i thought you i thought you
were going to say i know you're a liar
no i know you conan i know you're a liar
this is going on my tree and
i'll put this on my tree as well after i
use it
after you use it in the shower please
nice um nothing says christmas
washing your ass and hanging it on the
tree
you